let me bring in straight away uh the
president biden's foreign policy
spokesman from the national security
council admiral john kirby thank you for
talking to us um we were just hearing
now about these uh prisoner releases
prison award of war releases um
surprising i don't think anyone expected
that what more can you tell us about the
negotiations that took place saudi
arabia are clearly key yeah this would
be really for president zielinski to
speak to it was a it was a ukrainian
government president zielinski and in
his his administration who organized
this prisoner exchange if you will and
you're right there were several uh
non-ukrainian non-russian
individuals who who were exchanged
including two americans and i know some
several british citizens
we're grateful for the work
of the saudi government and the crown
prince in particular for helping arrange
this transfer this exchange and
obviously we're glad to see these
americans get home i would add as happy
as we are for them and their families
and of course we are we're glad to see
them home safe or be we'll be home safe
soon
this is not the time for americans to be
traveling to ukraine to fight in this
war and we have been very clear about
that there are other better safer ways
to support ukraine in this fight but
what a strange 24 hours it's been
because we saw yesterday morning
president putin
threatening nuclear war um mobilizing uh
hundreds of thousands of more troops and
yet on the same day we see this very
positive news with prisoners of war who
we thought would be executed actually
being released so
how do we read this i mean is is saudi
arabia's input here actually an avenue
for diplomacy i i think clearly in this
case it was and you saw the saudi
government
step up and be willing to help
participate in this exchange and again
we're all very grateful for that now
where it goes from here it's difficult
to know
again while this exchange is welcome i
think to your question we need to keep
things in perspective he has now called
up he putin has called up 300 000
reservists um he is now calling for the
sham referenda and places in the donetsk
and down in the south so that he can try
to achieve some political legitimacy
where he can't achieve any military
legitimacy uh in ukraine so there's no
sign right now and you've heard this
from president zielinski that the war is
coming to a close or close to becoming
uh to a close and that's why on the
united states part we're going to
continue to support ukraine but these
are dangerous times when when president
putin is is clearly on the back foot he
is threatening nuclear war he has the
largest nuclear arsenal uh in the world
i mean for people on the streets of new
york on the streets of london
what do you tell them what does the
white house tell them we certainly take
this rhetoric seriously and this is not
rhetoric that he hasn't used before
certainly over the last seven months
we're monitoring uh their nuclear
capabilities as best we can
and all i can say uh to the people here
in new york and to people around the
world as we have seen no indications
that we need to change our strategic
deterrent posture
so how does this war end
it should end today it could end today
if mr putin would just pull his troops
out and be done with it now clearly that
doesn't seem to be in his mind so short
of that
it probably will have to end we would
like to see it end in a diplomatic way
at the negotiating table
and we're going to do everything we can
to make sure that ukraine can succeed on
the battlefield so that
mr zolinski can succeed at the
negotiating table if and when it comes
to that some argue that it is it is the
case that that
the west just needs to
deliver on weapons more weapons in the
way that america has been doing the
british have been doing some european
countries not so much
are you the americans is president biden
frustrated
that more european countries are not
delivering weaponry in the way that they
could the president understands that
these are sovereign decisions that every
nation has to make and he also knows and
appreciates that there are some 40 other
countries who are contributing security
assistance to ukraine at various levels
clearly and with various different types
of capabilities that's to be understood
we respect that these are sovereign
decisions but just think about that more
than 40 countries and that's just
security assistance alone more than 50
countries have signed up to continue to
support ukraine and president zielinski
knows that he's appreciative he's
grateful for that what i can tell you
from the united states perspective now
we've done 21 drawdowns of presidential
authority
more than 15 billion dollars worth of
security assistance alone 25 billion if
you add all the financial assistance and
president biden was nothing but clear
yesterday that we're going to continue
to do that for as long as it takes